the crimes of Grindelwald completely
destroyed the franchise's Canon when
they introduced nagini as a human while
it was Alfonso coron's attention to
detail that made Prisoner of Azkaban so
jaw-droppingly amazing you won't be able
to guess which movie we gave the number
one spot this is every Harry Potter
movie ranked the fans had a lot to say
about this one for one thing they didn't
do service to Dumbledore and
grindelwald's relationship as it was
suggested as being in the books
Dumbledore was completely devoted to
Grindelwald something that many fans
attributed to him being in love with the
other wizard when they were young and
yet the movie seemed absolutely
resistant to making anything clear we
were closer than Brothers fortunately
the next movie addressed these concerns
but that isn't even to mention the fact
that this movie completely destroys the
book's Canon by introducing little plot
details like nagini being a human woman
and Credence being a Dumbledore none of
this really makes sense when you think
about it and all in all this money just
felt like a cheap cash grab the secret
to Dumbledore definitely took fan
opinion into consideration the
relationship between Dumbledore and
Grindelwald was much more obvious this
time around because I was in love with
you plus it helps that mads Mickelson
suits the role of the villainous
Grindelwald much better than Johnny Depp
did everything I never had but this
movie was still a bit of a jumbled mess
when it came to plot with everything in
the movie revolving around a magical
MacGuffin that barely made any sense
it's a real shame because the first
Fantastic Beasts movie wasn't all that
bad and we would have liked to see this
franchise take off a little bit more but
as it stands we're afraid the Fantastic
Beasts series just isn't stacking up to
the rest of the Wizarding World there
were a lot of cute moments in this movie
we really liked the magical creatures
especially the CGI niffler that left us
all wanting her own really it manages to
avoid a lot of the mistakes of its
sequels just by keeping the plot simple
and focusing on adventure if you're in
the mood for adventure one easy way you
can do that is by hitting that subscribe
button but back to Fantastic Beasts it
was Rowling's first Hollywood screenplay
and she may have wanted to start off
with something basic which was probably
a good call when you consider her later
screenplays still the characters are a
little underdeveloped and they just
aren't as widely beloved as the book
original characters definitely doesn't
help we just prefer the original movies
to this one even if they didn't always
get the books right the Order of the
Phoenix is the longest book in the
series and yet despite this the movie is
somehow the second shortest coming in at
only 2 hours and 18 minutes this
obviously cost them some key moments
from the book like the entire visit to
Saint mungo's Hospital for Magical
maladies and injuries which actually
gave us some key backstory on Neville
another missing moment from the books
was Dobby being the one to discover the
room of requirement which really costs
the series when it came to time for
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
part one really this is the book they
should have split into two parts the
fact that Sirius was missing from the
last few movies made his death feel less
impactful than it came across in the
books too where Sirius had been around
since meeting Harry the Order of the
Phoenix was long enough to cut it into
two parts the Deathly Hallows maybe not
but the studio decided to do it even
though the story wasn't set up for that
most of the movie is spent watching our
heroes argue and Camp you don't know
don't know how it feels which really
does start to get old after a while it
is nice to see a few moments between
Harry and Hermione but the slow pace
becomes even harder to stomach when you
consider just how anticlimactic the
ending feels Dobby's death just doesn't
have the same emotional impact when he
wasn't included in the Order of the
Phoenix such a beautiful nice that
doesn't make it a bad movie just like
the Chamber of Secrets it had some good
moments there just wasn't enough story
for the run time let's get one thing
straight the Chamber of Secrets is not
bad it has some great moments between
Harry and Ron stealing the flying car
and Hermione turning herself into a cat
look at my face look at your tail plus
you can forget gilderoy Lockhart I
didn't get rid of the band and Banshee
by smiling at there's just one problem
it may have been a little too dedicated
to getting the book right this movie
clocks in at 160 minutes which is way
too long when you consider that this is
one of the shorter books in the series
the movie tends to drag on and as much
as it's all accurate this just wasn't
the book that needed that treatment now
the Half Blood Prince on the other hand
could have used more of that the books
did a great job of setting up the
importance of the horcruxes the movies
not so much and a big part of that comes
down to the fact that so much of
Voldemort's backstory is missing from
the Half Blood Prince we get a little
hint as to how he got the idea it's cold
as I understand it horcrux but the
beautifully fleshed out reasons that
Rowling gave for each one was written
out and it made the Deathly Hallows part
1 all the more confusing when Harry had
no way to know what he was looking for
but that being said this movie's
cinematography is beautiful with a
darker color scheme to Mark the story's
darker tone which definitely sets it in
contrast to the bright and cheerful
colors of the Sorcerer's Stone The
Sorcerer's Stone is where it all began
this movie set the bar high right away
by bringing in some of the greatest
acting talent in English history from
greats like Alan Rickman a Severus Snape
and Dame Maggie Smith herself playing
Professor McGonagall we quickly forget
just how easy it could have been for
this movie to just be another
forgettable fantasy adaptation like
Aragon yet it took its source material
seriously and managed to give us a movie
that felt somehow both adult and filled
with magical Whimsy at the same time not
as adult as the Goblet of Fire mind you
but anyway if we do have one complaint
about this movie it's that the CGI might
be a little dated in places especially
when it comes to some of the Quidditch
scenes but it's still a solid fourth
place the Goblet of Fire was a huge
turning point for the books this was
when the series started to feel a lot
more adult with some pretty heavy issues
beginning to be introduced and director
Mike Newell handled this transition
beautifully with moments like the Yule
Ball where we can see our heroes showing
an interest in dating for the first time
you say dragons you can't get a date you
can I think I take the dragon right now
each of the three challenges in the
Triwizard Tournament are visually
striking and action-packed making for a
fun romp of a movie even if the
introduction of Voldemort wasn't quite
as menacing as it could have been still
you can tell that Mike owes a little
something to Alfonso quoron Alfonso set
the tone for the movies going forward
the Prisoner of Azkaban felt a lot more
adult than Chris Columbus movies which
had been a lot more Whimsical and more
polished looking you you may have even
noticed that our heroes started to dress
down a bit in this movie wearing both
muggle clothes and school uniforms that
looked a little less than tidy this is
because Alfonso Wanted the movie to look
more realistic and so he encouraged the
child actors to style themselves in
whatever way they would feel most
comfortable the Prisoner of Azkaban is
also responsible for bringing in Michael
gambin to play Dumbledore let's begin
the piece that is very good he'd go on
to define the role in every Harry Potter
movie to come it isn't quite as good as
our next movie it would have been
awesome to see more of James Potter and
his friends as animagi at school but as
it is it's still a pretty solid entry in
the list if the Deathly Hallows part 1
was all set up then part two is all
payoff this movie doesn't let up from
beginning to end and between its great
acting and impressive special effects it
feels almost operatic in scale this is
the climax that we've all been building
to and the Death Scenes definitely hit
hard when you've been watching these
characters grow and develop through
eight movies now that isn't to say it's
a perfect movie we would have liked to
see a more realistic death scene for
Voldemort for instance but that being
said we get to hear the answer to
questions that we've been dying to hear
for ages now like weather Snape's on
Harry's side or not after all this time
always whether we're talking about
Fantastic Beasts or Harry Potter each of
these movies have taken us on an
adventure If For Better or Worse what
did you think of our ranking of the
Harry Potter movies do you agree or do
you think of a different movie as your
favorite we're all fans of The Wizarding
World here so make sure to let us know
what you think down in the comment
section